I've just resolved the merge conflict
by moving my change of splitting
the asteroid into two fragments into
the new breakIntoFragments function.
However, I still need to let git
know that the conflict is resolved.
I can do this by
committing the resolution.
First I'll save the file.
Then I'll go back to the command
line and run git status.
This time, instead of showing
game.js as simply modified,
git shows the file was both modified.
That's because both branches modified
the file and then there was a conflict.
I resolved the conflict, though, so
I'll add the file to the staging area.
Now I'll run git status again, and
git says, all conflicts are fixed but
you are still merging.
Use git commit to conclude the merge.
So I'll go ahead and
do that, and once again git has already
filled in a commit message for me.
This time it notes that I just merged
the master branch into easy-mode, and
that there was a conflict in game.js.
Like before, I could change
this message if I wanted to.
But this message describes
the commit well, so
I'll leave the message as it is and
quit.
Now I'll run git log.
Notice that only one
new commit was created.
Git didn't create a separate merge
commit and a conflict resolution.
Instead, it just put them
both in the same commit.
Now to get practice resolving
a merge conflict, go and
merge master into easy-mode
on your own computer.
When you're done,
run the command, git log -n 1 and
paste the output in this box.
The -n flag means that git log will
only show that number of commits,
in this case, one.